we are not planning to have a passport
in the uk i just want to repeat that
because
that was the message from the vaccines
minister barely
two months ago but now the government is
announcing the first step of a vaccine
passport rollout
they're calling it covid certification
an electronic
all paper record of vaccination a recent
negative test
or natural immunity wembley will host
three pilot events the 21 000 who attend
the fa cup final
here in may are likely to require the
passports
the crucible in sheffield will have up
to 1 000 people inside
each day of the snooker world
championships the passports might also
extend to theaters and nightclubs
as long as social distancing is around
and that causes real challenges for us
to be able to open as viable businesses
again
so some kind of uh certification program
could help enable us to overcome some of
those challenges
but it would be proportionate and it
would be time limited
the data is encrypted by a trusted
certificate
and embedded into a qr code the
government has been consulting with this
company in denmark
about what a possible covered passport
app on your phone might look like
this solution has a higher security
level than any piece of paper or
certificate
it has to be impossible to
enter your health data here the only
thing you are exchanging
is basically a red or green light saying
i've been tested or vaccinated
and it's only been exchanged in that
moment between those devices
as things stand you won't need a vaccine
passport to go to the supermarket or get
on the bus
or even go to the pub but if wembley
stadium is to be full for the latter
stages of the european championships
football
in june and july then kovid's
certification
will almost certainly feature
and when vaccines are linked to
passports it is always divisive
i think we all do have to play a part
don't we so if that's the way that
it's gonna help us get back to normal
then i guess
i think it's terrible i do absolutely
terrible
it's just taking all your freedom away
it's just i don't like it i don't know
about other people i just don't like it
myself personally
i have a holiday boot this year so i'm
probably going to need a
vaccine passport in any way but um yeah
i think it's sleek
it's going in the right direction
several venues in liverpool including a
nightclub and conference centre
are also piloting for the return of mass
attendance events
this comedy club is trialing without
social distancing
but using testing before and after the
event
they won't require covid certification
a non-socially distant show so it'll be
the first one in the uk
in over the year so it'll be in a 1300
seater room but it'll be 300
seats and it'll be from the stage who
spends about 30 000 pounds in our main
venue to make it cover secure we were
doing we had extra stuff
on hand every night to do all the
traffic tracing and checking in with the
nhs app
and then we never had the single case
linked back to us in our venue so
we wanted we wanted to do this to sort
of have something on the record to prove
that it is safe because we know it is
safe
the great british summer trailed as the
light at the end of the tunnel is on
but first the great british research
project to decide how it works
martha kellner sky news